what the [ __ ] are you saying Joey did I
said that once you clean for 29 days
without smoking reefer that's it why go
back what yeah I like it
no if I [ __ ] stayed clean from reefer
for 29 days I go I'd let my lungs
[ __ ] heal from the abuse I have
inflicted on him the last dirty [ __ ]
edibles what about first of all I
haven't had an edible since like I broke
it in Boston September 29th so out of
respect for sober October I didn't do an
edible
I haven't done edibles I had that
something was wrong on my stomach so I
figured out I was lactose tolerant
lactose it's a lactose intolerant I
[ __ ] eat mozzarella cheese or milk and
I'm farting up you know it's an ass so I
had to cut that out of my diet no much
little cheese light on my american
cheese now no Swiss no more no Cuban
sandwiches
really it's [ __ ] crazy and then I had
to cut out the edibles that give me a
weird feeling just gone just gone
somewhere else that I didn't like the
hunger issues
oh the munchies the hunger issues after
11 o'clock were just monstrous like Here
I am working hard to lose weight I'd
stick to it and then I go home I start
with an apple another apple a banana
another banana then you gotta bust out
the salami sandwich with the [ __ ]
hammer you know it was just it was just
getting bad I could not control it not
uncontrollable the hunger from edibles
every minute after eleven o'clock for me
was on control well you can't blitzkrieg
do you don't just get like a no and it
starts early we're starting early two in
the afternoon then pop another two it
[ __ ] six
do you like vaporizing no no just
smoking I hate about your lungs vape is
at a hotel start in the morning well I'm
having coffee in my hotel room writing
my notes for the thoughts of the day mmm
because I don't wake up when hunger see
that was my problem all those years I
would need till one if you want to be a
fat [ __ ] don't eat til one when you wake
up because then you gotta make up for it
the rest of the day so now I have to
force myself to eat what do you mean
because a lot of you guys like the I
can't live with that what I mean my [ __ ]
goes up and down my blood pressure my
blood sugar so like I could never
intermittent fast but in the old days
I'd be coked up and I'd wake up speedy
still right so I wouldn't eat breakfast
but I'd start eating at one or two
o'clock and would not stop till [ __ ]
2:00 in the morning you saw me yeah I
bean those pink dot sandwiches like they
were nothing - meatball sandwiches at 12
o'clock because I wouldn't eat breakfast
I forced myself to eat you know for
years we were eating every six hours you
supposed to eat a smaller portion you
know I'm saying so yeah that's what
people were saying I got a breakfast and
I can eat two egg yolks a piece of wheat
toast and fruit and I'm good like four
sober October I gave up bacon I don't
need two pieces of bacon it's for five
points on Weight Watchers that's all I'm
alive but at least I'm allowed two
pieces of bacon two pieces of bacon is
all you really need
that's all you let me tell you something
when I was four 18 between you and I my
wife who's from the south would make the
whole packet of Oscar Mayer center cut
bacon the whole pack every morning that
was my breakfast eat all packet the
whole package with three eggs a half a
loaf of Wonder bread and butter and a 16
ounce coke the boot a coke on top of it
oh yeah I could drink two cokes for
breakfast
Oh remember I grew up in the East Coast
and I caught a bad habit early on after
my mother died I caught that I didn't
ever would need at all
I would leave and either at the deli I
went on there remember one [ __ ] cream
cheese and jelly on a on a roll was big
oh yeah you know what that does to your
system cheese and jelly for breakfast
are you sure I used to open up with
cream cheese and jelly on a poppy seed
roll with a 16-ounce coke for breakfast
four years
and I was in shape that that's the thing
you know you can't beat with liver
remember that nobody eats cream cheese
and jelly for breakfast on a roll no
more cream cheese and jelly no cuz
people know better now in Jersey and
those diners they kept those brand
muffins you're gonna get those bran
muffins they put them on the grill with
butter on them good googly moogly oh my
goodness you just chopped now I got a
bran muffin with raisins in it and ones
have no butter and nothing but they cut
them in half on the East Coast those
East Coast breakfast is horrible now how
long you been doing this Weight Watchers
thing now since December night so almost
a year yeah 11 months now yesh Allah
moyzisch they're dirty but that's nice
that's a good weight over that amount of
time cuz its gradual and I didn't the
only week I missed my fitness goals I
have to have 72 points of activity and I
only missed it one time I flew what's
the point of activity
so if I go to Muay Thai at nine I only
really it's an hour class but I only put
thirty minutes down a Muay Thai training
if we do circuit training with a ball
and ropes and [ __ ] then I put whatever
the amount if it's eight stations at 30
seconds of station you our heart rate
monitor anything or no let's not I want
to hear I want to see you know what when
I had that [ __ ] ear infection I used
to have to work out whether it plugs on
and I get high and go thro sidekicks for
Jesus you don't know what life is when
you had the ear infection the ear plugs
kept your equilibrium and balance no
would keep sweat from going in my ear
you don't know what life is when you're
working out you can hear your heartbeat
but yeah that's trippy [ __ ] you know
what Everlast has a ticker he's got an
artificial valve and he puts the
microphone up to his chassis here no I
don't want to hear that [ __ ] 60 minutes
60 minutes 18 years I think yeah he had
a heart attack a long-ass time ago
yeah that Valve yeah but if I was clean
of off weed for 29 days I might as well
go for it for at least a year
yeah marijuana just make a comeback just
to see what would it be like something
one thing that did happen last year when
we did sober October and I took a month
off when I started back again I get
nervous yeah give real nervous yeah he's
scared to do it and I go on stage I feel
real strange yeah somebody once told me
a great woman once told me that if you
think getting high in life is weird with
you stop getting high and it's a
different [ __ ] adventure and she's
feeling a lot of aspects I like called
ui1 October 2nd one that I got home from
the comedy store you know when you get
home from the original dog especially we
knew it was one of those nights when I
went in there and I was Rocky Balboa
I just touched gloves and I measured and
I just started going to the body the 15
minutes I remember driving up Laurel
Canyon young woman I do it myself and I
went home was like October 2nd it was
11:30 and I started smoking reefer to
calm down a little bit and I went down I
started with sign of the times by Prince
hmm and I just left on an auto play and
it just took me into a prince [ __ ]
cave and I ended up on beautiful once
when he start singing do you want him
and I called you up I'm like this is why
I can't do sober October yeah because I
get so high it might to come down off
stage and you get offstage you need
something since I don't drink I'm scared
to come up that hill drinking I hacked
the smoke reefer to come down at night
and music that's the only thing that
calms me down at night do you